an idea that will keep coming up as you
study economics is the idea of the four
factors of production which are usually
listed as land labor capital and
entrepreneurship and the idea here is if
you want to produce anything so let's
just say this circle is the production
process and this arrow is the output you
need inputs now you might have many many
many inputs you might need supplies you
might need a factory you might need
people to work in the factory you need
all of these different things but the
idea of the four factors of production
is that these things can all be
classified in one of these four groups
as either land labor capital or
entrepreneurship now these words have
meaning in everyday language and so some
of it might jump out at you of course if
you need to build a factory or if you
need to farm you need land to do so and
you can see that in this example here
where we see a farm clearly they need a
lot of land in order to have the farm
even in a garment factory this is a
picture of a garment factory for maybe a
hundred years ago even there they needed
to land on which to build the factory so
this floor is sitting on land and land
doesn't just have to strictly mean land
in an economics context it can mean
Natural Resources in general this could
be things like water or air or energy so
in some contexts instead of land some
people might say natural resources for
this first factor of production now
another important factor of production
and arguably they are all important is
the idea of labor to produce many or
most things
someone has to work on it so someone had
to plant these seeds and they will have
to harvest these crops the labor is very
clear here you see people putting in
work and in or in order to produce the
product right over there
now capital is an interesting one it
means one thing in everyday language and
it means something slightly more
specific when we talk about it in an
economics context in an economic context
capital is something produced to
reduce other things so examples of
capital would be tools that you use to
produce other things it could be a
building that you need in order to
produce other things it could be the
machinery in a factory so in these two
pictures there's many examples of
capital you could view this table and
the tools that these folks are using
that is capital you could use you could
view the whole building itself and all
of the light fixtures and all of that as
capital so all of this stuff is capital
the hangars that they're putting the
coats on after they produce it that is
capital in this farm example the capital
would be the buildings these were
constructed so that they could produce
the the food from the farm this little
looks like some type of machinery there
that is capital for the farm it's being
used to produce the output of the farm
now the place that that's different than
everyday language and everyday language
when people talk about capital they'll
often include financial capital
financial assets that could be used to
get benefit in the future things like
money but in an economic context we are
not considering financial assets we're
only thinking about things that were
produced in order to produce other
things the fourth factor of production
is entrepreneurship entrepreneurship in
our everyday language means putting
things together so you're trying to
create other things when someone's an
entrepreneur you might imagine someone
who's trying to start a business in an
economic context it has a related idea
entrepreneurship is putting together all
of the other factors of production so
that you could actually produce things
you can't just randomly build buildings
and randomly plant seeds someone has to
think about how do you put these things
together so that you can produce things
in a reasonable way and obviously you
want to produce as much as possible
given the other factors that you are
putting into the production a related
idea and it sometimes is used
interchangeably in an economics course
is technology so sometimes you'll see
the four factors of production is land
labor capital and entrepreneurship and
sometimes you'll see it listed as land
lay
our capital and technology but when you
see this when you see technology as a
factor of production don't think about
it as technology in everyday language
where you think of computer chips or
software when people are talking about
technology as a factor of production
they are really talking about
entrepreneurship they're talking about
the know-how of putting together the
other factors of production in order to
produce that output finally I want to
leave on one idea the idea of the two
types of things that could be produced
from all of these factors of production
broadly speaking we could produce
something that could be used to produce
more things and we already talked about
it we could be in that situation be
producing capital goods so that could be
that we are constructing a factory that
itself maybe produces tools for other
people to use in some other production
process the other option we have is to
produce what are known as consumption
goods consumption goods consumption
goods are goods that are just used it
might make people happy they might find
pleasure in it but it's not being used
to produce other things and because our
production resources are scarce there's
a trade-off when a society or a factory
or whoever decides how much capital to
Bruges versus how much consumption goods
you need some consumption goods
otherwise frankly we wouldn't have
clothing on we wouldn't be eating nice
meals we wouldn't be able to enjoy our
lies but at the same time you also need
capital if we did only consumption goods
at some point we wouldn't have all the
things we need to produce the
consumption goods so it's a very
interesting trade-off that we'll explore
more in future videos